foreign
[Music]
[Music]
when i first heard this news
i was shocked i'm not shocked at the
same time i was surprised and not
surprised at the same time
i wouldn't say i prophesized it but i
knew it was coming
now when you say i knew it was coming
it does seem like or sound like as if
the person deserves it it's like you
know when you say to someone you knew it
was coming
not in this instance the reason i've
decided to do the video now in a
collective manner is because yesterday i
was angry and i was upset
and today i wanted to do it in a
composed manner and give you guys some
understanding because allah subhanahu wa
in the quran tells the psychology of a
few individuals he tells us the
psychology of the mustards apostates he
tells us the psychology of the
kun he tells us the psychology
of those who are
disbelievers hostile disbelievers and of
those disbelievers who will not host out
towards us allah tells us a psychology
and this psychology does not change
is consistent 1400 years ago three
thousand years ago from the time of adam
alaihissalam allah says that in the
quran
but what do we learn from it
now if you guys remember brothers and
sisters when it comes to the issue of
the far right tommy robinson written
first yeah
jada franz and all these law
do some people think i was bored i
thought you know what let me make a name
for myself let me get some fame let me
go confront these big big figureheads
no
the reason why i went and confronted
them and
people like them like isis is because i
know the things that they utter there
are going to be consequences
it's not just hey he just spoke freedom
of speech
there is consequences
to speech not just actions to speech
so i knew when people at the far right
spew nonsense and dehumanize muslims
there is going to be consequences
muslims are going to suffer at their
hands their soldiers are going to take
action like we saw in christchurch we
saw in friends before we saw in canada
recently yeah
even though that was a mustard yeah
which again makes perfect sense why
allah when well islam applies to
punishment these individuals because
they would not leave the believers alone
the same thing with isis the same thing
with isis when they spew their nonsense
we know that there's going to be
consequences brainwashed individuals
following them and taking it out on the
general this non-muslim population
innocent people going about their life
the same thing happened here
do you guys remember my debate which was
distasteful which i dropped myself to a
pig's level
if you mentioned there i mentioned i
said one of my problems with you this
fake mustache you can't sort of
yeah is that your nonsense of spewing
hatred towards muslims in india and the
this would be jb whatever the hell they
call them to allah destroy them is that
it comes at the consequences of muslims
being attacked when somebody like apos
who has done videos where his following
is they have a hate towards islam
they take the matters in their own hands
my wife when she's walking down the road
when her hijab is ripped off when i am
walking down the road with a beard or a
phobe and somebody tries to run me over
do you guys remember that in that debate
and i always repeat this statement
i always read the statement where am i
coming with all this you're saying
brother ali okay where are you going
the point i'm trying to make is the
following
this coward
who when shaku's man gave him in his
face yeah the little
this little cow this little boy yeah
this coward once he got sparked in the
face once he had to resort to a knife
he had to resort to a knife
he came with a knife when it was a fist
battle
if i was shaykh with man and i'm sure
she's not done this i'm sure but he
didn't have it if i was in america and
guns were legal i would make sure i've
got a rifle in the back and i've got a
minimum two guns yeah laying around
somewhere and i would have a pistol in
my belt
and believe me the mo the moment i see
this coward with a with a knife i would
make sure i empty my whole clip on his
head
honestly that means i'm not saying in
america if it's legal somebody's coming
to you with a knife to kill you my
friend make sure i'll make sure those
bullets don't miss
because you tried to attempt to kill his
life you attempted to and why
and let's tell let's go to the quran
what does allah say in the quran
allah says in the quran
and we saw what they were doing to the
believers
and they harmed and they persecut
basically killed them for no other
reason but
that's the reason
that's the reason that is why they do it
and allah mentions in different verses
this is why when i was talking about
this coward this apus and david and isla
when i was saying this some backstabbers
came to their rescue and said oh you
know you're accusing him of things where
he's never ever uttered directly to
muslims to be harmed now why am i
mentioning this because the point is
this
yeah two individuals
who i don't want to mention
they were belittling it
i'm the point i was trying to make there
and you and i'm trying to make a point
here is i know
these people this guy who did this to
sheikh uthman alhamdulillah yeah okay
the guy next day he's in darwin like the
guy's walking like his happy days i'm
not doing this because of him i don't
know it's not that soft of mine i'm
proud i am proud to have a co-believing
brother like him a person of knowledge
like him hamdulillah we are we're not
worried about shaco's man trust me i'mma
worry about the guy that got punched in
the face
i'm not worried about it i have no doubt
i have no doubt oh
this guy watches apus david wood and
people like uh princess that flipping um
what's his name is uh egyptian prince
whatever his name is say okay he watches
people like this
that is the reason why he was watching
those statements and he was stating that
you know jesus is
a [ __ ] broad guy i got you you wanna
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you and your muslim
[ __ ] [ __ ] dog you wanna [ __ ] you
i'm an infidel what's up [ __ ]
you wanna you know you think i'm scared
of you
why did you attack shaykh of man the
question is i spoke to shaka's man's son
i said aki was it a road rage because i
just wanted to be clarified clarify you
can see in the messaging as well yeah i
said aki was it a road rage and you can
see it here on the screen he said no it
wasn't a road wage he knew shepherd's
man now the question that needs to be
asked is at the beginning you remember
when i said when somebody i knew it was
coming but in this instance sheikh of
man
what does shah's man do is he affiliated
to any of these groups isis al-qaeda la
no
has he ever advocated
um
death threats to anyone or you know any
other kind of stuff no
we know shaq was man from a couple of
things he destroyed david wood he rinsed
out some shimon the other clown as well
got uh uh rinsed as well and he has been
doing dawah
and calling to tawheed and he's been
having shahadas like his happy days
now the question that we all need to ask
ourselves
why would
these individuals
have a problem with that this is the
crux of the matter allah is telling us
in the quran yes in surah
allah says verse 39 if i'm not mistaken
it says
permission to fight has been given to
those who have been fought
yeah if you look into the commentary it
says that when the companies heard this
they knew that they are allowed to now
defend their self abu bakr allah said
okay you go to surah baqarah verse 190
fight in the way of allah those who
afford you surah mumtain verse 8 allah
does not forbid you from being just and
kind to those who have not kicked you
out of your houses or for you
the point i'm trying to make is this
guys
these people you know they use these
verses this jihad verse in the quran etc
while i i believe everything that allah
has mentioned about warfare it is
because allah knows their psychology how
does it usually start when the
revelation came to the prophet salallahu
how does it stop number one ignoring his
he's lost it
when the revelation carries on
when the revelation carries on with a
message etc mock him
when you start seeing things that get in
serious people are taking shahada etc
okay now try to challenge him
intellectually oh now you see it doesn't
work what you're coming with battle like
allah says
falsehood comes when truth is spoken
falsehood perishes and by its nature
it's bound to perish and then from there
what happens is when you realize
intellectually you can't when you get
somebody intellectually what do they
resort to
violence
threats
remember the fact that shaco's man got
on his car member then they do threats
because why they're like okay we first
dismissed him then we mocked him then we
laughed at him then we tried to
challenge him now it's frets now after
this what did they do to the companions
they persecuted them they killed them
they boycotted them they tried to starve
them they kicked them out them from
their houses and to the level where they
started to fight and kill them
and then sword hatred hydrogen where
they have a right to defend itself after
13 years we see the same thing happening
and we will see the same thing happening
to yamakayama
the point i'm trying to say is this
whenever i confronted the far right or
anyone and when i've debated this coward
this little boy apos yeah and i said the
same thing to him
i said the savings because i know
i know and i made that statement watch
it for yourself my own wife when she
goes out
hijab might be ripped off i don't know
when i'm walking somebody's going to
stop me
or someone
this doesn't mean you know i've
prophesied the point i'm trying to say
is this it is not surprising
because allah is telling us in the quran
there's psychology when spoken
except preach the deen except preach
that shows you how powerful the quran is
that shows you how powerful islam is
that when they see shahadas can you
imagine this they throw all these doubts
prophets marriage to aisha uh islam says
this and that about infidel and people
are still flocking to islam it goes
against logic and rationale to them
they're thinking how is this possible
yeah rotten wood these guys are making
videos and it's like people are still
[ __ ] i'm sure they're like this
doesn't add up
because the hack
when the hack comes
it will destroy battle falsehood and
that is exactly what's happening
and don't get it twisted we've had some
same things different not to that level
we've had warnings from the police yeah
okay
they would only try to stop us by
killing us
that is the only way
as long as we breathe
and as long as blood is running through
our ways
through our veins inshallah
you will hear our tawa
and if we go and there will be hundred
people like us million people like us
better than us where nobody yeah
that will come and make the deen the
kalam of allah
and that is our aim and our objective
you are never going to stop us
this attack was something to shackles
man this was to every single one of us
okay and this attack is not going you
know what it's going to do it's going to
make us stronger and it's going to make
his dao stronger it's going to make him
much stronger anyone that's watching
this go and subscribe to his channel
subscribe to his channel like his happy
days go subscribe hit that subscribe
button like this happy days okay
inshallah our aim is what our cause is
one with shaykh with man and with all
the brother that uh duart our cause is
one and we are going to push that
inshallah and inshallah we're gonna get
his channel to inshallah millions of
subscribers inshallah and people watch
around the world and they accept islam
inshallah like allah says in the quran
they bite their hands out of rage
may you die in your age
for attacking a man just because he says
yeah where's the media outlets where's
the outrage ah it's muslim blood it's
cheap as you guys
um i'll say you guys you know killed
millions millions of muslims
imagine if a muslim did that and you
dare to call us terrorists
alhamdulillah
we're going to carry on our tawa
alhamdulillah inshallah hundreds and
thousands of reverts are coming to islam
and let that burn you
burn in your rage inshallah sheikh man
is back the very next day doing his
dawah calling to tawheed and we will
call to tawheed
that's all i have to say brothers and
sisters may allah bless you guys
inshallah alhamdulillah let the enemies
you know as you can see burn like this
wood
and allah i was going to start
fundraiser for what the guy doesn't need
fundraiser i think the guy who got
punched in the face is a fundraiser you
know maybe his jaw or teeth was broken
you know subhanallah so again uh just
one little uh nasir to shake off man as
well inshallah if he's watching this
please be careful uh alhamdulillah you
have full trust in allah as well also
make sure you have some brothers around
you because these people are cowards
they don't this you know they'll
backstab you know these people will do
anything to stop your mission they will
do anything slow mission they fear
nothing but what you utter and what you
utter is the quran and the sunnah till
next time may allah protect them
inshallah assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi